دلال بنت فتح الله ما ببالغ لو بقول ما
احد ما يعرفها بعد اللي عملته جعفر العمده
وصدمات الحلقات الماضيه دلال اللي بتلعب
دورها الفنانه ايمان العاصي هي الزوجه
الثانيه لجعفر العمده والزوجه الثانيه
ايوه ولكن هي الحب الاول ودلال بتكون من
الستات اللي بسموهم يعني كيادين كده
مستعده تعمل اي شيء عشان تفضل هي اللي
فايزه بقلب جعفر وبتكون كمان طايحه بالنار
اهلها ونار زوجها ولكنها دائما بتختار
زوجها
المسلسل من اول ايام وعامل حاله في الوطن
العربي كله وبكل شخصياته لكن في اخر
حلقتين تحديدا جرعه اهتمام الناس بدلال
تضاعفت فالسته دلال صدمت الجمهور وخيبت
امال كثار من المشاهدين اللي دايبين في
جمالها فمن بعد ما كانت على اساس حبيبته
المفضله عنده المظلومه وتايهه بن جعفر
واهلها اتضح انها عدوه وان هي ورا خطف
ابنه اللي جعفر سيرلو سنين بيدور عليه
واللي المسلسل كله اصلا بيدور حوالين
حوالين انه احنا نلاقي الولد هذا من اول
يوم يعني لسان حال الناس من وقتها كان كل
ده يطلع مني كدلال
من القاهره تنضم الينا النجمه ايمان
العاصي اهلا فيك معنا يا ايمان ومبروك هذا
النجاح
اهلا ازيك عامله ايه كل سنه وانتم طيبين
والله يبارك فيكي ازيك يا ساره عامله ايه
الحمد لله تمام منورتنا اليوم يعني ايمان
انتي جميله وبريئه وحبوبه وكلنا بنحبك
والكلام ده كله جيتي في دلال اول شيء
اقتنعنا انه وداد هي اسوا وحده في العالم
الان دلال تفوقت بمراحل يعني كيف متعامله
مع رده الفعل والصدمه تبعت الناس
بصي هو مش عارفه لسه تعامل خالص قاعده في
البيت كده مستخبيه
قوي اقابل الناس
بس انا مخدوده زي الناس بصراحه جدا
بس وصلتك رده فعل الناس وانهم زعلانين
والهجوم والكلام ده كله
هما الناس حابين اوي حسناء الشعبيه مسميين
الحسناء الشعبيه
وحابين قوي حاله الحب اللي ما بين دلال
وجعفر
وانه دلال دي الحضن الحنين بتاع جعفر واي
حاجه يترمي في حضن حنان دليل ويحكي لها كل
حاجه
فمره واحده دلال هي السبب الشوكه اللي
محطوطه بضهره طول العمر يعني
انصدموا الناس جدا بس انا كمان يعني يقال
انك انت حتى متاثره بالشخصيه حتى جوا
البيت يعني في حاله خوف وقلق منك يعني
مقصره جدا ههه
بس بنتي بتعمل الدور يعني يعني كنت متخيله
النجاح هذا
اه بصي هقول لك حاجه واحنا كده لما كنا
بنقرا المسلسل وكنا بنعمل بروفات واحنا
بنصور
استاذ محمد سامي عنده طاقه كانت وهو دي
اللي كان بيزرعها كل ممثل في التيم
المسلسل كله ان احنا هننجح نجاح احنا قبل
كده ولا يعني قدامنا 10 سنين هنفضل نبقى
مبسوطين بالنجاح ده فانا كنت عارفه ان في
نجاح نجاح قوي جدا جدا ان شاء الله بس مش
متخيله بالنجاح العظيم احنا كل يوم عندنا
نجاح كل يوم عندنا حكايه كل يوم
بنسحب جمهور اكبر جمهور اكبر يعني الجمهور
بيكبر اكتر اكتر كل يوم فانا نجاحها عظيم
بس مش البهار ده لا هو يعني
كل يوم ما شاء الله في الترند يعني
متصدرين بس انت كيف تم اختيارك في العمل
يعني لو انا من البدايه جيت تخيلتك في ده
الدور محلب بيجيك صراحه في هذا الدور يعني
ما هي دي المشكله يعني حتى كان
اللجنه حبيبي وصاحبي محمد رمضان كان لسه
في انترفيو بيقول ان انا دايما هو قالها
لي في الاول فلما ابتدينا دايما بتحط في
دور البنت الحلوه البنت الرومانسيه البنك
الكيوت فانا ده انا ده عملي عزمة كتير قوي
وخليني اقعد كتير اتعطل مش عايزه اشتغل
لانه خلاص ما فيش ما فيش حاجات ثاني ما في
تحدي
اضيفها للكاريكتر الكيوت استاذ محمد سامي
ده كان اختياره في الاول انه انا اعمل
دليل وانا اتخضيت وبس اتبسطت جدا جدا
وخمست وحسيت ان هو كان يعني حاجه بدور
عليها طول عمري من بدايه مشواري الفني
ولقيتها وبقيت ماسكه فيها بكل يعني قوتي
انه خلاص يعني دي فرصتي استاذ محمد ثاني
هو واجهه نظره وطبقها ومن اول مره فكر
فيها في ايمان تعمل دلال والحمد لله يعني
الحمد لله الحمد لله عملنا يعني شغل كويس
لا لا ما شاء الله عليكم بس حتى بنتك علقت
على الموضوع يعني حطت بوست وكتبت قالت انه
يعني انا خايفه او تعرفي خلينا نشوف
الكليب خلينا نشوف الكلب اسود
[موسيقى]
الله يخليلك بس يعني هي قالت انه يعني انا
كيف اعرف اذا انت خطفاني كمان ولا مش
خطفاني يعني البنت جالها حاله قلق يعني
ريتا بنتي مش من عدتها اصلا هي تعلق على
اي حاجه انا اشتغلتها او بقدمها وكده بس
هي ريتاج وبرده مش من عادتها ان هي يعني
سابع حاجه طويله قوي كده يعني الجلده
بيزهق بسرعه فتابعت المسلسل ومتابعاه
وقاعده طول الوقت تدوس لي اللي هو يعني
بجد يا ماما انت خطفتي بجد انت عملتي كده
بجد انت الشريره قوي كده فهي ريتاج مصدومه
وتحاول يعني تخرج من فكره ان انا يعني
بحاول تخرج من فكره ان انا مامتها اللي
عملت كده وان هو ده تمثيل وبتاع بس هي مش
عارفه تركب معاها بتقول يا مامي انت
فضحتني في المدرسه ههه
يعني مسكينه طب اكيد بتاخد كتير تعليقات
خصوصا كل الناس بتتابع المسلسل بدي اسالك
يعني طيب اوكي انت خرجتي من مثلا او شفناك
في موضوع انه الكيوت خرفتي منه والكلام ده
كله بس ايش رايك في موضوع انه قصه اربع
زوجات هل مثلا ممكن ايمان انت تعمليها في
الحقيقه
الحقيقه اتجوز لا ما افتكرش لا انا ست
غيوره جدا جدا جدا يعني
خالص خالص يعني خلاص يعني اه انا مقتنعه
ان هو حلل ربنا وكده بس كل يعني لا يكلف
الله نفسا الا وسعها وهي بصراحه يعني حاجه
مستحيله بالنسبه لي كده اكيد اتعرض عليا
حاجات كتير شبه كده بس
حلو حلو كويس انك انت عارفه نفسك يعني
غياره وما اقدر
معايا اكيد اكيد طبعا الست اللي مش سعيده
خلاص ما بتقدر تسعد اللي معاها طيب على
سيرتك كمان الاشياء اللي صارت في رمضان
انت كمان وقعتي في براثن رامز واتعورتي
ايش اللي صار
ظهري قعد اسبوع يعني عندي وجع بس يعني مش
اتعورت يعني الحمد لله رجليا هو ما كانش
حاجه ما حصلش حاجه عظيمه الحمد لله يعني
بس يعني اه طبعا اتالمت وانا بلف في
الغساله يعني يعني هضم ولحم يعني طب
وبعدين انت قلتي قلتي لرامز انه ما راح
اسامحك هل فعلا ما سامحتيه ولا خلاص
سامحتي ولا لا طبعا مسرحاه يا دعابه يعني
رامز من زمان جدا
واحنا اصحاب انا بحب رامز جدا جدا يعني
احنا احنا اخذناه كده كله على بعضه بجنانه
بتفكيره لما حد بيتخيله بحبه يعني لو زعلت
وقتها لا على طول يعني هو رامز مخلينيش
امشي غير وانا مراضيني يعني بس انا بحب ما
بعرفش ازعل منه يعني ولا في الحياه
الشخصيه برضو بيعمل اكثر من كده في الحياه
يعني كمان
رامز حبيبي بيرحمنا في التليفزيون لا لا
لا لا لا لا لا لا من جد
بس خلاص هو كده خلاص هذا يعني
طيب
ايمان طبعا السؤال المعتاد في ده الموضوع
ولكل الناس محتاره فيه انت كنتي عارفه قبل
ما تروحي انك رايحه لرامز
ما كنتش هروح طبعا لو كنت عارفه اه ما كنت
هتروحي انا ما فيش حاجه في الدنيا انا
بخاف جدا انا جبانه جدا جدا
فانا يعني حتى لو انا عايزه اروح لرامز
انا معرفش رامز ممكن يعمل فيا ايه الحقيقه
لو كنت عارفه كنت واقفه مستحيل اوكي فانت
كنت عارفه انك رايحه مشاركه في برنامج
انا باحاول ان هو ممكن يعني ممكن انا مثلا
ابقى حظي وحش ل انا هبقى الضحيه الحقيقيه
بجد بقى يعني مش هيبقى
مقلبعنك وانا بفانك بسرعه قوي اه اوكي طيب
ايمان انت منورتنا اليوم يعني وما تتخيلي
احنا كلنا هنا بنتابع المسلسل وبنتمنى لك
كل التوفيق صراحه
والشيء الاضافي انه انت على ما يبدو واللي
فهمته انك انت في الايام الجايه حتكوني
اكثر شرا كمان لسه في يعني في صدمات والله
يا جماعه
هي الشريره ده كله امه شريره
ايش تعريف الشريره عندك يا ايمان
لا يا شريره
طيب تبرعي طيب اوديها فرصتها كل حاجه ليها
سبب صح ولا لا صح عندنا اسبوع هنفهم فيه
دوافعك الين اخر رمضان
طيب نورتينا يا ايمان 22 لسه في 23 وفي 24
ونشوف ايش المبرر وبنشكرك جدا على ظهورك
معنا اليوم شكرا لك كانت معنا من القاهره
النجمه ايمان العاصي شكرا